-Hey, guys,
it's time to take a look
at the stories
making headlines today
and weigh the good with the bad.
It's time for "Pros and Cons."
Here we go.
-♪ Pros and cons and pros
and cons and pros ♪
-Now, tonight we'll be taking
a look at the pros and cons
of wedding season.
Things are opening up.
Lots of weddings
can finally be rescheduled.
So let's take a look at the pros
and cons of wedding season.
Here we go.
Oh, well.
That's --
Make it a double.
-[ Imitates squirting ]
-Thank you.
-Aww.
-There we go.
[ Smooches ]
-[ Pops lips ]
-Oh, forgot to --
-Aww.
-I mean, it's very,
very expensive.
It's almost ridiculous.
-Need a down payment.
-Hey.
[ Cheers and applause ]
How's your bracket?
-Bad.
[ Laughter ]
-Even through the mask,
you could understand.
He's like, "Bad."
Yeah.
Are you even close?
-No, not at all.
[ Laughter ]
-Wow.
-Gonzaga's still in.
-Are they really?
-I'm still in it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not a perfect bracket,
but I'm still in the mix.
-You're still in the mix.
You're still in
the conversation.
-Right now I could still --
Yeah.
-You still could
take it all, right?
-Yeah, man.
I got a lot riding on this, man.
-Oh, my God.
How much?
-My house.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-I can't tell the wife and kids.
-No.
-You know?
I can't even let them know --
I'm not that type of --
Also, I know nothing
about college sports.
-True.
-So why would I do that?
-For the juice, for the feel.
-Yeah.
-So you can feel alive.
-Energy.
-Yeah.
So your dead soul can wake up
and go, "I'm alive."
-Do you know how much ApeCoin
I dumped into this thing?
-How much --
[ Laughter ]
You were an early adopter
of ApeCoin.
-I'm dumping all sorts --
Dogecoin, all that stuff.
-ApeCoin, bananas.
-Tossing it in there, man.
[ Laughter and applause ]
"Hey, we're getting married
if you wanna --"
His window was rolled up.
Just like,
"Somebody turn him off."
"I remember when Larry
used to be single, man."
[ Laughter ]
Hey.
[ Laughter and applause ]
There you have it, everybody.
Those are your "Pros and Cons."